[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
hello Walter I'm Martin
we're doing a very complex subject today
for some it might seem
easy
but if you get into this it can be
Troublesome so and it's something that's
very relevant to our time oh I think
sometimes we underestimate the real
relevance of it so let's ask for the
holy spirit to guide us our heavenly
father we ask
today again like always that you send us
the holy spirit to guide this discussion
and thank you for everything that you do
for us in Jesus name amen amen
abomination of desolation
can you hear the rumbling
I think that's the reference to an old
sermon I hear the rumbling
and it deals with this particular issue
how close are we to the Fulfillment of
this prophecy and what does it actually
mean
because it's very important that we
understand these things
because it takes a
a unique understanding
when you deal with the abomination of
desolation because there's also people
that throw this into history
and say it is not future it's got
nothing to do with it and some
futurism throw it into the far distant
future
so we of course believe in the historic
continuous model of the Bible
and Martin really let's just put this
bluntly it's the only logical one to
adhere to or else the Bible was written
only for the people in the past and only
for the people in the future and the
entire block of humanity in between has
got nothing to do with the scriptures
yes there's absolute nonsense no
descriptions is there for every one at
every single point in history
so if you lived in the time of the
Reformation
then there would be blocks of scripture
that will tell you where you are in the
Stream of time and whatever is being
said is relevant for your time as well
so futurism really has no future
[Laughter]
that's a very good very good point
yeah so let's look at this abomination
of desolation
and see what we can see
Jesus speaks about the abomination of
desolation foretold by the Prophet
Daniel
in the singular without specifying more
about it so which of these references
was Jesus referring to
and of course we can ask ourselves the
question what is the abomination of
desolation I mean you don't want against
something and you don't know what it is
makes no sense every time like for
instance Babylon you've always said if
you won against Babylon you must Define
Babylon otherwise what's the point right
so what does the abomination of
desolation represent in our day that is
to say when will we know that the sign
announced by Jesus for the flight of his
people has been fulfilled I mean this is
pretty important
it affects your very life right exactly
so we need to know what the abomination
of desolation is
and it's spoken of by the Prophet Daniel
so if we look at the word desolate
Matthew 24 15 when ye therefore shall
see the abomination of desolation spoken
of by Daniel the Prophet
stand in the Holy place whosoever
readeth let him understand
Mark 13 14
but when you shall see the abomination
of desolation spoken of by Daniel the
Prophet standing where it ought not
let him that readeth understand
then let them that be in Judea flee to
the mountains so Mark gives us a little
bit more detail right it's interesting
that in the modern translations they
leave out in Mark by Daniel the Prophet
spoken by Daniel the Prophet
now the the argument of these people is
always well it says it in Matthew why
would you want to repeat it in Mark that
irritates me that so that I could scream
that's true what about the second and
the third witness you know it's it's so
pathetic it is because the thing is that
is the excuse that's the excuse but it's
so easy to read the other parts and do
your study and then you forget about
that and then you can fall into the Trap
about the higher criticism that says
Daniel wasn't a prophet or he didn't
even write Daniel yes he didn't write it
yes or it wasn't written at the time
when it was written it was written after
the event
and even then they run into trouble
because it goes right up to our time so
how would he write it after the event if
it doesn't even take in place yet
so let's not go there the higher critics
or irritating Bunch they're influenced
by the Jesuits and we should write them
off as irrelevant to the topic correct
except as adversaries
stick to the Bible and the historic
continuous correct
Luke 21 verse 20 and when you shall see
Jerusalem compassed with armies they
know that the Desolation thereof is nine
this is a parallel text
so it's always good to have a parallel
text so the abomination of desolation
and here again the Abomination when it
is standing in the Holy place a parallel
text when you shall see Jerusalem
compassed with armies they know that the
Desolation thereof is nigh
now remember Matthew and Luke are double
application prophecies
what is the sign of your coming and of
the End of the Age
so there's a then time prophecy and an
end time prophecy a literal fulfillment
and a spiritual fulfillment and we
mustn't leave that out of the equation
because then we will get lost and we
have to separate them
but of course the literal application
has a lesson in type for the spiritual
application so you cannot separate them
say well that's parts that's future yeah
they're actually linked
that's such an important statement
because 90 of the people or 100 of the
time when you have a conflict on this it
comes because they separate them yes you
can't
so let's go to a statement in the great
controversy
Jesus declared to the listening
disciples the judgments that were to
fall upon apostate Israel
and especially the retributive Vengeance
that would come upon them for their
rejection and crucifixion of the Messiah
unmistakable signs would precede the
awful climax the dreaded hour would come
suddenly and swiftly
well that's important isn't it well of
course last event shall be rapid ones
and the Savior warned his followers when
he therefore shall see the abomination
of desolation spoken of by Daniel the
Prophet stand in the Holy place
who sir readeth let him understand then
let them which be in Judea flee into the
mountains
and she quotes Matthew and Luke
and when the idolatrous standard of the
Romans should be set up in the Holy
Ground which extended some furlongs
outside the city walls
then the followers of Christ were to
find safety in flight
when the warning signs should be seen
those who would Escape must make no
delay throughout the land of Judea as
well as in Jerusalem itself the signal
for flight must be immediately obeyed
you a chance to be upon the House Top
must go must not go down into his house
even to save his most valued Treasures
and those who were working in the fields
of Vineyard must not take time to return
for the outer garment later side while
they should be toiling in the heat of
the day
they must not hesitate a moment lest
they'd be involved in the general
destruction
that's a very important statement
takes us back to lot doesn't it yes same
well if he wasn't in Sodom in the first
place
that would have been an improvement yeah
and if he hadn't carried that's where
the second part comes in and his his
wife was looking back
in other words her heart was more there
than outside of the city
and so the combination of all of that
cost her her life there's another
statement in the spirit of Prophecy I
think it's in Patriarchs and Prophets
where she states clearly that
the reason for lot terrying
was because of the positions yes and if
he stood firm and went out when he
should have his wife probably would have
been saved yes so it is good to listen
and lot is an example of those that move
at the last moment it could be very
costly
okay and another thing to remember or to
notice is this has to do with the first
Siege but remember Martin that the first
stage is a type of the second Siege and
what's important is you might get lost
and think that this is the second Siege
in its saying that you're not even don't
even go into your house if you're on the
roof this sounds like a fleeing quickly
it is a fleeing quickly but it's
important to remember that this is on
the first Siege the reason being
if you think it's only for the second
seeds you might be caught unaware
well let's go into some details what is
he referring to when he talks about
the Desolation and when he talks about
the Abomination
and the combination thereof yes because
like you've made asked in the question
to which one is it referring yes so you
can explain there all right let's go to
the verses in Daniel Daniel 8 13. then I
heard once Saint speaking and another
Saint sent out to that certain saying so
he's listening to Angels speaking
because he's in vision
which spec how long shall be the vision
concerning the daily sacrifice and I
remember sacrifice is added
it's cursive in the original so it's not
there it's added
so we could read it how long shall be
the vision concerning the daily
and the transgression of desolation to
give both the sanctuary and the host to
be trodden underfoot
so he's talking about a time prophecy
the
2300-day prophecy
and here's the question
the transgression of desolation so
desolation has to do with transgression
transgression causes desolation
very important
and to give both the sanctuary and the
host to be trodden underfoot there are
two aspects here
the sanctuary will be trodden underfoot
and the host will be trodden underfoot
so what is the sanctuary referred to
well the Tabernacle that Moses spoke or
the temple
so people can say what's referring to
the literal destruction of Jerusalem but
here it cannot be because it's talking
about the 2 300 days and the end thereof
so it must have a wider connotation it
must refer to whatever the end time
application is
but we learn from the literal
what the end time application is what
the anti-type is so we have to discuss
the sanctuary what it stands for that's
being trodden underfoot and the host
well the host is God's people so the
God's people will be persecuted
and the sanctuary will be trodden
underfoot in the process
good
Daniel 9 17. now therefore Oh Our God
hear the prayer of thy servant and his
supplications and cause thy face to
shine upon thy Sanctuary that is
desolate
for the Lord's sake so help me to
understand this
so that I can communicate it
what is going on here he's asking the
question and particularly he's
interested in the 2 300-day prophecy
which has a start
and an end yeah because it's a Time
prophecy from the issuing of the decree
to restore and build Jerusalem and to
then comes the Messianic portion of the
prophecy and then the end and there's no
way that you can get around it if you
have a starting debt then you must have
an end date and you take a day for a
year
and if you take this day for a year
principle and you apply it
then the Messianic portion
is completely filled and satisfied
therefore the same principle must apply
to the rest you cannot use futurism
throw it into the future throw it into
the past pre-terrorism it is a historic
continuous flow from the issuing of the
decree through the Messianic era to the
end and because it has a start the
decree but the Sexes went out in 457 if
you add the time it ends in 1844 whether
you like it or not that's it that's
where it ends and there are so many
people that argue about the 1844 but
they should just think what happened in
1844.
the great uh
lines opened up for the proclamation of
the Gospel of electronic age started at
that time to communicate the message
with the morse code the great lines of
traveled opened up in 1844 the
opposition came in the form of spiritism
in the form of a communism in the form
of every ISM that you can think of
communism all of them started in 1844 if
that is not an important year then I
don't know what is an important year so
that's the point and obviously
Satan will attack this obviously because
he has to he has to attack the timeline
and he has to ridicule
and I see Martin when I listen to
the Evangelical preachers
more and more they are attacking the
Miller Right Movement yeah now all that
Miller did was take a prophecy and apply
the principles and come to a conclusion
all right they had the event wrong
because he didn't understand the
sanctuary but we're going to talk about
it which in any case is also in the
Bible that it was God's will that it
would happen in having his hand over
okay so why doesn't why don't these
evangelicals ridicule the disciples that
got the event wrong when Jesus was
crucified
they got the event wrong exactly they
got the event wrong they got it wrong
you want me to repeat it they got the
event wrong yeah okay but they're still
in the Bible but they're still in the
Bible and they're still relevant yeah
and it's important that we understand
that type has to meet anti-type
and if we don't understand that then we
don't understand why Jesus had to die to
bring an end to the ceremonial law
because it pointed to him yeah
so that's an important thing that we
look at that
okay
so he wants an answer and so we should
also want an answer
Daniel 9 27 and he shall confirm the
Covenant with many for one week
and in the midst of the week he shall
cause the sacrifice and oblation to
cease
and for the overspreading of
Abominations he shall make it desolate
even unto the consummation and that
determined shall be poured upon the
desolate that sounds pretty complicated
right it can be if you just read it like
that if you just read it like this and
you take it out of that portion of the
prophecy which actually contrasts the
Messiah with the anti with the anti
Messiah let's put it that way the the
one who builds on the one who destroys
and he shall confirm the Covenant with
many for one week that's that last week
in the 70-week prophecy
so who will confirm a covenant obviously
the Messiah yeah
right and in the midst of the week
that's three and a half years into that
final week he shall cause sacrifice and
oblation to cease
now they in the in futurism apply that
to the Antichrist
and it's and then they throw him into
the past or into the future it's
ridiculous
the way the sacrificial system came to
an end is with the death of Jesus so ask
yourself the question
did Jesus die in the middle of the week
in other words three and a half years if
you take the day your principle three
and a half years after the commencement
of his ministry yes or no yes and it's a
fulfillment of Prophecy
so he put an end to the sacrificial
system by becoming the perfect sacrifice
that's important right we need to
understand that because if you don't
then you can end up with Catholicism and
then you're on all sorts of directions
all right so he
will cause the sacrifice and oblation to
cease
some people will say but he didn't do it
the Romans did it they if you want to
argue this way
but he says I lay down my life and I
take it up again voluntarily yeah
and for the overspreading of the
Abomination so now we're talking about
the negative side Jesus does not bring a
negative he only brings a positive
he shall make it desolate even until the
consummation and that determined shall
be poured upon the desolate so the
Abomination is set up thereafter at some
stage and goes through right to the end
until it itself is destroyed yes and
that will be with the rock that's come
loose without any perfect
all right so we need to know who's
making desolate how is he making this
look well obviously there was a literal
application
the Romans came the Roman army came they
surrounded Jerusalem they made it
desolate they flattened it
but there must be a spiritual
application because
if you go to the first one they will the
sanctuary and the host will be trodden
underfoot
for that entire period so what happens
there we'll have to look at that
Daniel 11 is the next time we pick up
this word and arms shall stand in his
part and they shall pollute the
sanctuary of strength you see every time
the sanctuary is involved
and shall take away the daily
sacrifice is added and they shall place
the Abomination that makes desolate so
in other words they will put the
Abomination that makes desolate in the
place of
right so we need to understand what this
means
remember that the the temple was
destroyed
so now some people say well the temple
must be rebuilt or whatever no no no
we're now in spiritual
realm exactly it's so important what you
just said because a lot of people like
you say get stuck there it has to be
physical again yes you can't you can't
jump from the one to the other you
cannot make the anti-type the same as
the type because then you violate the
principle the anti-type is always a
greater fulfillment of the localized
small example
but you learn from the exhaust exactly
and then we have Daniel 12 11 and from
the time that the daily shall be taken
away sacrifices added and the
Abomination that makes desolate set up
there shall be a thousand two hundred
and ninety days now we're not going to
go into that prophecy we've done it
before the 2000
3290 days Etc we're not going to go into
the breaking down of that prophecy which
are basically expansions of the 1260
which ends in 1798. we're not going to
go there we're only going to concentrate
on this desolate but there's a time
frame which tells us this has nothing to
do
with the literal Temple exactly and
that's I just wanted to mention that as
well
the only thing we can mention about this
is it's not literal it cannot be applied
to literal all right so let's go back to
Daniel 8 13 which is basically the first
time that he talks about it
and it it gives a general overview
so the angels are talking about this and
they're talking about transgression
that makes desolate right
to give both the sanctuary and the host
to be trodden underfoot so we must now
ask ourselves after Jesus's crucifixion
and after all of those events
even after the destruction of Jerusalem
which was done by Pagan Rome
when did this desolation of the
sanctuary take place in a spiritual
sense
because it continues right until the end
and has its culmination
in what Jesus had to say on the subject
go and study what Daniel said so we need
to understand
so Martin let's look at the sanctuary
and ask ourselves what did the sanctuary
stand for and how can history tell us
was it made desolate
what it stands for not the literal one
no what the literal one was signifying
in a spiritual sense correct all right
so here we have the sanctuary this is
just a model
and there was an opening there were four
posts there
and you ended in only in this place
nowhere else did you enter in
and around it was this white linen
now the Bible tells us clearly what
white linen stands for it stands for the
righteousness yes of the Saints but we
have no righteousness Christ is our
righteousness so obviously it stands for
righteousness
but you have to enter the door now who
claimed to be the door Jesus Jesus
claimed to be the door all right so you
come to the father through whom through
Jesus through Jesus did he say that yes
is there anybody else that you can come
to the father by none no one but no you
sure the pope just said different than
Kazakhstan didn't he unfortunately all
roads lead to Heaven well he he actually
said all roads lead to Rome because he
says it's only through him that you can
get there all right so he's so kind to
to open that door for everyone it seems
right
but the Bible tells us there's only one
door and that is Jesus
when you enter it
you are immediately confronted by the
altar of burnt offering
that's it so something dies there
namely a lamb yeah
so the penitent sinner
kneels down places his head on the lamb
confesses his sins
he doesn't have to speak out loud the
priest doesn't have to hear what he has
to say
and in type transfers his sins to the
innocent lamb so who does the lamb
represent Jesus again right we've been
through this a thousand times we'll just
make it simple
but we want to know how it was made
desolate right
and the priest himself he's got white on
so that represents righteousness so who
does he represent Christ again all right
now Christ is the lamb and he is the
priest yeah
so the lamb dies
so it would be a bit of a disaster if
you killed the priest because that would
be a problem so we have a double image
here
the lamb represents Christ and dies for
the sin and the priest represents Christ
who is the mediator
now the priest himself is not mediating
he is the type of a mediator that's very
very important it's again it's not
literal he's a type he's it's spiritual
and in the Bible a priest is someone who
brings an offering he has to make a
sacrifice
all right Pastor is someone who is a
shepherd
who is a teacher
but he is not a priest because
it doesn't bring a sacrifice but let's
just stop there all right so this little
lamb is actually then tied to the horns
of the altar in other words it is
associated with that altar you cannot
separate it from the altar
and it dies in the state so in type you
enter into the relationship with Christ
through the door which is Christ you are
confronted with the altar which
represents the cross
and the lamb represents him and the high
priest represents him
once you've gone through that process
which is called justification
because when you enter into the door
immediately you are surrounded by the
white linen
is it covered by righteousness covered
by his righteousness then you enter to
the labor
which represents the washing of rebirth
and the Holy Spirit now
so there you go you have now become a
representative of Christ
a disciple
then you're entered into the holy place
in time
now this is where the priest officiated
and in it was the candlestick
Jesus said I am the light of the world
so here's the Candlestick if you go to
the Book of Revelation he's officiating
amongst the candlesticks yes okay
churches in the early part of Revelation
also in there was the table of showbread
which had the unleavened bread and or
the the spices and the frankincense and
all of those that represents the sinless
Christ and the body that was given for
you
then also in the Holy place was the the
altar of incense
and there the high priest officiated
and it symbolizes the prayers of the
saints that are being made acceptable to
God through the mediation of Christ
then you entered into the most holy
which again was separated by a veil so
it's interesting you had you had the
door and then you had the veil and then
you had a second Veil
and behind the second well you had the
Ark of the Covenant
we've already discussed what was in it
we don't have to talk about Aaron's rod
and all of those things and the pot of
manner The Ten Commandments were in
there written with the Finger of God
and above it was The Mercy Seat and
above that two angels looking down on
the mercy seat in a very contemplative
form
there you have the Plan of Salvation
how do I come to God I enter in through
the door which is Christ I accept his
offering in my behalf
I receive the righteousness of Christ
which is justification I am cleansed and
empowered
by the Holy Spirit to become a disciple
of Christ and a representative and that
can also be done through baptism yes and
represents baptism and it represents the
washing
the cleansing and then I partake of
Jesus the light of the world which is
the word of God
Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my part and by partaking of
the word I become involved in
understanding the character of Christ
emulating the character of Christ
internalizing the character of Christ
which is represented by the showbread so
whenever take of that bread it's
unleavened bread in other words if I do
not partake of the body of Christ I have
no part in it I have to internalize him
but if I internalize him I internalize
him without sin because there's no
Leavin in it no leaven yeah
right
so in other words what does this
represent sanctification
and without sanctification it's not
possible to see God so I cannot stop at
justification I have to proceed to the
rebirth and I have to proceed to
sanctification and the prayers that I
offer are being made acceptable to God
and all the sins that I confess are
recorded in that Sanctuary because the
blood is applied to the horns of the
altar
of incense
so there is the hard disk
with billions and billions of terabytes
containing all confessed sins the record
of sins it's like a court situation
if I have
being a criminal
and let's say I was a robber and I got
caught
I go to court I get a sentence I go to
jail
I get pay my dues in jail I am set free
the record of sin does it still remain
yes so if I get caught again they will
look up the in the books and say excuse
me the record says you have done this
therefore you have no extenuating
circumstances this time around it's
going to be worse for you than the first
time yeah yeah that's how it works
so the record of sin is recorded over
there which is good because now your
record is recorded and eventually it
will be cleansed
the sanctuary will have to be cleansed
of the record of sin that happens on the
anti-typical day of atonement then you
stand before God as though you had never
sinned right
now the Ten Commandments they stand for
the law of God they are a transcript of
his character
if you do a parallel study in the Bible
you will see
that each one of them the law is the law
is the law is the law is Paul will do
that on a regular basis and then you
will see God is God is God is and it's
exactly the same
so it's a transcript of his character
and you have The Mercy Seat
which Shields you from the condemnation
of the law
and the angels look down upon The Mercy
Seat the hillisterion with amazement
because it costs the price of the Son of
God in order to apply that Mercy because
if God is 100 Justice then Justice must
be done
and justice
demands the life of The Sinner the wages
of sin is death yeah so Justice was
satisfied when Jesus being the corporate
man being God himself that's very
important
takes upon him the whole of humanity and
its sin and pays that price
right you see it you cannot take away
the consequences of the transgression no
no so he paid the price in other words
the law stands it could not be done away
with Justice demanded death Justice is
satisfied and now Grace can abound yeah
Mercy can abound
because the penitent sinner
has paid the price the second death
so The Mercy Seat is very very important
it Shields you from that condemnation of
the law which should rightfully come
upon your head It Came Upon his
and the right there here in the
courtyard it was placed upon his head
and that's why when you don't
confess your sin
that Mercy Seat
is moved away and you stand before God
correct
now we have to answer the big question
how was the sanctuary made desolate
let's take a system that arose which is
called Roman Catholicism
so when paganism was removed
then there could be the rise of the
little horn power
paganism had to be taken out of the way
and when that was out of the way
the Antichrist system could develop
now what did it do it destroyed the
sanctuary message so let's go
via Catholicism through the sanctuary
you enter into the door and Catholicism
is the door now Jesus Christ no it's the
church all right so you are saved
through the church
God has a church
but you're not saved through the church
the church is a hospital
he's the physician
all right so you enter in through the
door in other words you are saved by
coming into the church
then you have to partake of the
sacraments
right yep
now Catholicism teaches that Jesus never
died for you
you are not saved by the blood of the
Lamb you are saved by your obedience to
the church and the partaking of the
sacraments
in other words there is merits in
performing the sacraments
so that gets rid of the altar
the altar is made desolate because Jesus
never died for you he was just an
example of obedience yeah
but he never died for you
but isn't actually the door also made
desolate by then changing it to the
church completely every single aspect
is made desolate
so the door is desolate
the righteousness of Christ is no longer
his righteousness it is your good works
your obedience so the white linen is
made null and void the lamb is made null
and void the baptism which is rebirth in
a spiritual sense has been transferred
to infant baptism in other words
membership to a church without a
cognitive decision so the labor is made
null and void
who becomes the light of the world
the church the church is the light of
the world it will tell you what is right
and wrong by its own volition
it will tell you so it's not Jesus
that's the light of the world it's the
darkness of the church it is the
magisterium yeah the pope and the
Bishops that Define Truth for you
uh Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path no the catechism is
written by the church is a light unto
your feet and a lamp unto your path you
will listen to that
and then when it comes to internalizing
the body of Christ they will make it a
Perpetual sacrifice
when the Bible says by one sacrifice he
has forever made perfect so the table of
showbread is destroyed
then the mediation the altar of incense
the high priest Jesus is the mediator no
the priest becomes the mediator you have
to get forgiveness from your your sins
from the priests and he is the mediator
not Christ
now what about
the most holy place now there's a veil
between the two Jesus said the vowel
represents My Flesh
and when Jesus died on the cross that
veil was rent from top to bottom showing
that the separation that was there
between Jew and Gentile according to to
what Paul has to write on the issue is
gone and the gospel is for the whole
world
now take the Ark of the Covenant inside
is the law
inside is the rod of Aaron inside is the
part of manner
now the law
is the transcript of God's character
but here the law has been changed yeah
it's desolate it's desolate because once
you change the law
you break one you break them all I took
out the second they changed the fourth
they reworded the whole rest and took
out all the promises
and took out any private position that
you had that didn't go through the
church so the entire Sanctuary message
the entire Plan of Salvation has been
totally changed it is an abomination
it's unmistakable you cannot see it any
other way and it makes desolate yeah
there is no way to be saved now
when I am entering in through Christ and
I'm surrounded by the righteousness of
Christ whose Merit is that that I
receive Christ's that that Merit is
reckoned towards me
in other words I appropriated by faith
it is not my righteousness it is his
righteousness
now who distributes Merit in the
Catholic system the Pope the pope
distributes Merit
and he distributes the excess mirror
Merit by the Saints and even Christ so
he has this treasury of Merit
and he meets it out
now seeing that Christ never died for
you you are still responsible to pay the
price for your own sins that's why they
develop purgatory
and in purgatory you pay the price for
your sins now who can apply mercy and
relieve you from that punishment again
the Pope the pope can do that
and then he also has occasions when he
does it on a massive Indulgence when he
takes his little hammer and hammers on
the door
so that he can open it so that the souls
can come out of purgatory the one who
supplies the mercy
and becomes The Mercy Seat is the Pope
so Martin are the Angels looking in
wonderment at the pope at The Wonderful
Mercy that he dispenses and I think it's
more disgust it's a this gusting
abomination
I cannot think of a better word no
if there were one I'm sure the Bible
would have used it so it's an
Abomination the whole system is an
abomination
imagine if you partake in any aspect
yeah
of the Abomination
are you then part of the Abomination yes
because there's not one part of this
Sanctuary message or system not one that
can be tampered with it's like the law
of God you cannot tamper with the Plan
of Salvation
so they've not only tampered with it
they've totally destroyed it they've
made it desolate what does the word
desolate mean nothing there's nothing
left of it nothing
so if there's nothing left of it and you
go in there and you partake of a simple
thing
let's say the labor
the labor comes after a decision to
confess your sins and to accept the
sacrifice of the Lamb so it must be an
adult decision yes well let's turn that
into an infant baptism you've destroyed
part of the sanctuary
if you acknowledge the papacy as the
high priest of Christendom
aren't you then desecrating the
sanctuary for sure definitely
okay
If You Preach futurism or pre-tourism
are you not uh desecrating the sanctuary
yes because you are taking Christ out of
History throwing him into the past
throwing them into the future and the
poor people in the middle
I've got nowhere to go
you are desecrating The Plan of
Salvation you are desecrating the
sanctuary
it's being made desolate
so actually like you said any church
organization or anybody for that matter
that partakes in any one of these
desolations that the the Roman Church
has done
forms part of it forms part of it and
you're in big trouble
so Revelation 3 verse 18. this is the
council to the loudest sians and that's
the very last Church on earth right
and they have to bring the final message
to humanity which includes the Three
Angels messages of Revelation chapter
14. which actually brings you back to
the complete Sanctuary message yes if
you don't if you don't link it to the
sanctuary then you've missed the point
yeah then you're not doing what the
Bible says namely written by the Prophet
Daniel let the reader understand
and in fact if you go to Revelation
chapter 12 let's just take the not
Revelation Daniel chapter 12.
then you will read there in verse 9 and
he said God thy Way Daniel for the words
are closed up sealed till the time of
the end
and the time of the end is defined as
the end of the time times and half a
time which is 1260 days day for a year
1260 years that's time period of papal
Supremacy
and he said go thy Way Daniel for the
words are closed up and sealed till the
time of the end so that is any time
after
1798 many shall be purified and made
white in other words receive the
righteousness of Christ
and tried
but the wicked shall do wickedly and
none of the wicked shall understand
and then comes verse 11 and from the
time that the daily sacrifice is cursive
shall be taken away and the Abomination
that makes desolate set up there shall
be
1290 days that's the verse that we had
right now let's just have a look what it
says here
this church this final Church gets a
council so this must be very important
to buy from me gold tried in the fire
now the gold
is faith and love
and love is bound to the Commandments
that thou mayest be rich and white
raiment
that thou mayest be clothed so the
righteousness of Christ is a very
important issue in the end
and that the same of thy nakedness do
not appear
and anoint thine eyes with I solve that
thou may see so it's very important that
we understand the issues we need the
gold
win which is Faith and love we need to
have the white Raymond so that we can be
clothed and our nakedness not be exposed
we need to anoint our eyes so that we
may see
now here's an is a statement in
testimonies for the church volume 6 page
426 today
a large part of those who compose our
congregations are dead in trespasses and
sins
they come and go like the door upon its
hinges
for years they have complacently
listened to the most solemn
soul-stirring truths but they have not
put them into practice therefore they
are less and less sensible to the
preciousness of Truth
the stirring testimonies of reproof and
warning do not arouse them to repentance
the sweetest Melodies that come from God
through human lips justification by
faith
and the righteousness of Christ
do not call forth from them a response
of love and gratitude
though the Heavenly merchantment
displays before them the richest jewels
of faith and love
though he invites them to buy from him
gold tried in the fire and white raiment
that they may be clothed and I solve
that they may see they steal their
hearts against him and fail to exchange
their lukewarmness for love and zeal
while making a profession they deny the
power of godliness
if they continue in this state God will
reject them they are unfitting
themselves to be members of his family
wow that is an important important issue
such strong words but it's still rooted
in the word
cannot be not denied
all right let's go back to the sanctuary
by the way this word desolate
occurs many times in the Bible but the
prophets that use it the most
are Isaiah and Jeremiah
and then of course we have it in Daniel
yes four times
many pastors says Jeremiah 12 10 have
destroyed my Vineyard they have trodden
my portion underfoot they have made my
Pleasant portion of desolate Wilderness
many pastors have destroyed my Vineyard
my church and have trodden my portion
under the foot they've trodden upon the
sanctuary now that power
it was to arise that would make the
sanctuary desolate was wrong we saw how
they did it they tried upon the
sanctuary and then they tried upon the
house yeah
how many people have been killed that
opposed the view of Rome
millions billions millions billions
over the centuries there's more blood on
our hands than any other organization
therefore it is sanctimonious of the
pope now to say let's forget about that
history and pretend that we Are Holy by
throwing all Doctrine out of the window
in other words trampling some more on
the sanctuary yeah
okay
let's read another verse here in in
Jeremiah verse 11 they've made it
desolate it's pretty plain what he's
referring to and being desolate it
mourneth unto me and the whole land is
made desolate because no man layeth it
to heart
it's basically what we read now in that
statement yeah
behold says Luke 13 35 your house is
left unto your desolate and verily I say
unto you shall not see me until the time
come when you shall say blessed is he
that cometh in the name of the Lord
Martin there's a lot in that verse that
we don't recognize
for example
if your house is desolate it's empty
yes empty of what of this Plan of
Salvation and empty of Christ yeah of
Christ Christ is not in it and they will
not see him until when
the end and then he comes with judgment
yes why because they've thrown him out
of the house that's it and uh Kazakhstan
did they mention him once no did they
throw him out of the house yes they will
not see him until he comes
with judgment they will not see him
that's it the house is desolate it's
empty it's an empty house they've
trodden upon the sanctuary
Revelation 17 16 and the ten horns which
they are sourced upon the Beast these
shall hate the and shall make a
desolate and naked and shall eat her
flesh and burn her with fire eventually
the nations of the world will realize
that they've been duped by the system
and they will take a Revenge their
revenge on her when they realize they're
all lost but it's too late too late way
too late
Revelation 18 19 and they cast dust on
their heads and cried weeping and
wailing saying alas alas that great City
wherein were made Rich all that had
ships in the sea by reason of her
costliness for in one hour she
is made desolate
so is the economy involved in all of
this definitely okay so we have to talk
about all of these issues and see where
it fits in again when we apply history
and current events to what's happening
in the world today so the pastors have
destroyed the vineyard
they have changed the Plan of Salvation
And even if it is fractionally
they have still participated in it and
also in Jeremiah here he was talking
about the Jewish Nation yes or that time
Israel that was going to be destroyed
and like you've mentioned before just
important to remember that their house
like we've seen in Lucia is left to them
desolate so it's desolate there's no use
in looking at Israel the literal
um country
to be seeing the end times that's what
the evangelicals do but the house is
desolate why is it desolate because
they're throwing Christ out
now even if some assume to take him back
in it's not the same Christ it's one
that's going to bring National
deliverance and not one that's going to
bring deliverance from sin
sin is the enemy that must be destroyed
so they're constantly making the entire
Sanctuary message null and void because
they're still hopping on their tradition
and Martin we have to look at this again
and see how it applies so let's go back
to what the question proposed there in
the beginning was
so Jesus speaks about the abomination of
desolation foretold by the Prophet
Daniel in the singular without
specifying more about it which of all of
these references was Jesus referring to
well some of them were with regard to
the literal one for example Wei explains
the 70-week prophecy and where he says
that the sanctuary will be destroyed
but the word abomination
and the words associated with it are a
type so you can't separate them we have
to take them all yeast into account
so what does the abomination of death
desolation represent in our day
it represents any form of Christianity
or any religion that makes the sanctuary
message null and void so the one that
did it on a literal scale and persecuted
those that opposed him
what's the paper scene that's it so when
Jesus speaks about these things and when
he talks about this verse when therefore
you shall see the abomination of
desolation spoken of by Daniel the
Prophet stand in the Holy place whoso
readeth let him understand
parallel text at the bottom in Luke
chapter 21 verse 20 and when you shall
see Jerusalem compass with armies they
know that the Desolation thereof is not
so in a literal then time prophecy
when you see the army of Rome
surrounding Jerusalem standing in the
Holy place
now the holy place was as we read in
that other statement some furlongs
outside the city in fact Nehemiah had
proclaimed a clean area where not even
the merchants were allowed to come into
and they weren't allowed to enter on the
Sabbath to do their work so the Sabbath
was very very important and this holy
place was a cleansing of the merchants
interesting right yes and they were not
to desecrate the Sabbath that's a type
so the merchants may not desecrate the
Sabbath at the end of time
now we've been saying a lot about that
and about the introduction of Sunday law
and all of those issues and they want to
introduce a four-day work week but it's
interesting that the companies will give
you Tuesday or Wednesday off yeah but
not Saturday
that's very interesting
but let's not go there so when we're
talking about this in a literal sense
when you see them coming
then let them flee yes then flee now
there were two sieges
the first Siege
they surrounded the city cestus and then
they departed again when you see
Jerusalem encompassed by armies well
when it's encompassed you cannot flee
so that's too late yes it had to happen
so there was a moment of reprie and they
withdrew so there was a moment of
reprieve and the Roman armies Departed
and the Jewish zealots went behind them
and killed many of them which incensed
the Romans
[Music]
so it was obvious they were going to
come back and the sign was here they
were then they were gone
flee get out
out of the cities and then they came
back under Titus
and they destroyed the city
and they destroyed it finally the final
destruction happened on the Sabbath day
yeah yeah that's very interesting the
Sabbath is always in the mix
when they plant their standard what is
their standard it's their Pagan symbol
their mark under which they marched what
is the Pagan symbol or the mark of
Catholicism the Sunday the Sunday they
say the Sunday is the mark of our
Authority so when they start bringing in
Sunday legislation and Surround God's
people with this threat
then you are surrounded by the power the
military power of Rome who can make war
against them
and then there was a withdrawal
and from then until now there's an
interim period when it comes again it'll
be too late it's too late
okay
when was the anti-typical first Siege in
1888 with the Blair bow where Sunday
legislation was to be brought in in the
United States of America
and this was uh delayed or it was
withdrawn after the arguments of Alfonso
Jones
and those arguments were irrefutable
but they would come again yeah so since
1888 we have been living in the time
period between the two sieges
and already after 1888 the spirit of
Prophecy says the time has come to leave
the cities
so God's people ought to leave the
cities
all right there are many that are not
heeding the call they should actually
never be in the cities exactly but some
of them are
so how do you get out of the Cities
that's a good question it is especially
for people that might be stuck
and some people say I can't get out of
the city I can't get up
well then others must prepare the way
you must link up to people that have
this mindset that want to get out ask
God to open the way
and some he will enable and they must
prepare the way so that others can come
up now obviously you can come out still
at the last second
because we have another type which is
lot
they came out at the last second but
it's harrowing and there were casualties
yes Lord's wife was a casualty so it's
not the best way to go so if you cannot
go out yourself then ask God to help you
link up with those that have a similar
mindset
uh make sure that there is a pathway for
you to open but when you see it coming
when you see that second Siege and the
pagans stand at the Sunday being lifted
high is it being done at the moment yes
constantly get out of the Cities get out
of the cities that is what we must do
all right now who is involved in this
Army the entire ecumenical movement the
entire world because the kings of the
world give their power unto the Beast
they are involved the pastors are
involved they've trodden under the
sanctuary everyone that has taken part
in any form of that Sanctuary being this
and who is the one who's supposed to
know and to warn the world
is unfortunately what asleep asleep and
what is it that they should trump it
with the loudest voice that they
possibly can the righteousness of Christ
imagine I'm tempted to take my Bible
and to read you the letter to the
loudest sins
let's do it okay let's go to the letter
of the lot of sins you will tell me
there's no such letter in the Bible and
I will argue with you and say yes there
is
so let's go
to Colossians
remember that none of the wicked will
understand
but the wise says Daniel will understand
okay
now verse 16 says and when this epistle
is read amongst you calls that it be
read also in the Church of the loud
sians
so Colossians is a letter to the loudest
sins
he refers to another letter which is
obviously lost so this is the only
letter we have left to the loudest sians
so what is important that we should know
about
it regarding the issues of the end time
so if you go to verse 9
in my Bible it is bold face of which of
chapter one chapter one
and it stays bold face until you get to
verse 17.
all right so obviously that is one
important paragraph
now let's read this for this cause we
also since the day we heard it do not
cease to pray for you and to desire that
you might be filled with the knowledge
of his will none of the wise Wicked will
understand but the wise says Daniel will
understand so he wants us to have
knowledge of his will in all wisdom and
spiritual understanding
we need that
that you might walk worthy of the Lord
unto all pleasing being fruitful in
every good work and increasing in the
knowledge of God
strengthened with all might according to
his glorious power and to all passions
and long-suffering with joyfulness
that's called sanctification
giving thanks unto the Father which has
made us meet to be partakers of the
inheritance of the Saints in light
who has delivered us from the power of
darkness and has translated us into the
kingdom of his dear son
point 14.
in whom we have Redemption through his
blood even the Forgiveness of sins
is that part of the sanctuary message of
Catholicism no is it part of the
sanctuary message how are you saved by
the blood to the blood Catholicism
denies the blood yes
if you acknowledge the head of
Catholicism as a leader in your thinking
you've become part of an abomination
hmm
okay
so in whom we have Redemption through
his blood even the Forgiveness of sins
If you deny this point
you have become part of an Abomination
that's it he Christ forgives sins
nothing nobody else so who are we
dealing with
when we are dealing with Jesus Christ
who is the image of the invisible God
the firstborn of every creature for by
him were all things created that are in
heaven and that are in Earth visible and
invisible whether they be Thrones
dominions principalities Powers all
things were created by Him and for him
who is he is God Jesus deny the Divinity
of God if you take Christ out of the
equation your house is desolate desolate
and he is before all things and by him
all things consist what is he he's the
Creator If you deny this you are
desolate because you're denying your
source of life you've actually thrown
him out of the window Kazakhstan did
they mention him once no
the house is desolate desolate and
anybody who signed that document same
desolate
and he is the head of the body
uh uh who was sitting in white the Pope
presiding over the opening and the
closing ceremony
Martin
desolate desolate desolate and anybody
that
clings or
goes with anything or acknowledges goes
into ecumenism
part of it and he's the head of the body
the church
who is the beginning the first board
from the dead that in all things he
might have the preeminence did he have
any preeminence at Kazakhstan
none desolate
all right let's read a little bit
further just for clarity's sake to make
quite sure for it pleased the father
that in him should all fullness dwell
and having made peace through the blood
of the cross
by him to reconcile all things unto
himself by him I say whether they be
things in Earth or in things in heaven
is this pretty clear
in reading it like this
there is no way you can deny this no you
can't the Divinity of Christ all right
so the last Church on Earth must preach
Redemption through his blood we must
preach righteousness
sanctification justification
verse 21 and you that were sometimes
alienated and enemies in your mind by
Wicked Works yet now has he reconciled
in the body of his flesh through death
did he die for you yes how can they
desecrate the sanctuary by preaching the
opposite and if you take who was this
that died in the flesh the person that
was described in the previous verses yes
God yes
all right Martin
so
there's no doubt that you cannot deny
any of this
and then it says
through his death to present you holy
and unblameable and unreprovable in his
sight if you continue in the faith
grounded and settled and be not moved
away from the hope of the Gospel does
their modern Sanctuary message take you
away from the hope of the Gospel yes
absolutely it takes you away from the
hope of the Gospel just turn to chapter
two it also takes you away from the
judgment
so when he comes back with a reward they
also deny this yes and they won't see
him until he comes back with the reward
that they don't want
so chapter 2 and I would that ye knew
what great conflict I have for you and
for them at Lauder
and for as many as have not seen my face
in the flesh that their hearts might be
comforted being knit together in love
and unto all Riches of the full
Assurance of understanding to the
acknowledgment of the mystery of God and
of the father and of Christ in whom are
HID all the treasures of wisdom and
knowledge doesn't the pope have a
treasury yeah of Merit
and is it all in him or is it based on
Saints and pre-lights that have murdered
Millions because they disagreed with
them
yes Martin this is serious
rub down to verse 8 beware lest any man
spoil you through philosophy and vain
deceit after the traditions of men
doesn't the papacy say that Traditions
is the context in which everything must
be interpreted it's higher than the
Bible yes
and the Bible calls this vain deceit
after the rudiments of the world and not
of the Christ for in him dwelleth all
the fullness of the godhood bodily and
you leave him out of a discussion for
the sake of compromise and of Brotherly
Love
in verse 11 in whom also ye are
circumcised with the circumcision made
without hands in putting off the body of
sins of the flesh by the circumcision of
Christ and then comes this important
statement in verse 14 blotting out the
handwritings of organ ordinances that
was against us which was contrary to us
took it out of the way nailing it to the
cross
and then verse 16 let no man therefore
judge you in meat or drink or in respect
of a holy day or new moon or Sabbath
days which are a shadow of things to
come
but the body is of Christ let no mind
beguile you of your reward in a
voluntary humility and worshiping of
angels demon worship House of demons
must be absolutely clear as to what law
is talking about here ceremonial shadow
of things to come the law was never
shadow of Ten Commandments was never a
shadow of things to come it's a
transcript of his character if anything
it points back to Creation
but this one pointed towards Christ yes
and that includes the ceremonial
sabbaths they all pointed to the
ministry and atonement of Christ so
Martin this is all very very important
and then of course it tells you uh how
you should live to live a Christian Life
Etc
so basically this is an epistle to the
loudest sians as we as we saw because in
verse 16 he says of chapter 4 must be
read to the louded sins
so what is it that laodicea needs to
understand it needs to understand the
preeminence of Christ yeah
anything that negates the preeminence of
Christ must be rejected
anything anything that leaves him out is
a desolate and doesn't put him
on ways on where he's supposed to be God
yes righteousness by faith do they need
to understand that yes if they don't
include righteousness by faith in their
in their salvation they have no
salvation
any form of righteousness by works do
they have to understand
ceremonial law
and type and anti-type yes if you don't
aren't you going to look towards literal
Israel today exactly that's going to be
confused right
but looking at literal Israel today and
thinking that God is going to save
literal Israelite Israel is neglecting
the words your house is desolate yeah
you have been grafted out if you don't
craft Christ back in you remain desolate
okay
we are supposed to avoid division
do we do that very well in laodicea no
no
we are supposed to avoid vain philosophy
hmm are we very good at that
and avoiding it no
human ordinances do we like to think
that works might be more important than
salvation by faith
so all of these things are
in this epistle to the laodiceans
Colossians
and Martin
when therefore you shall see the
Abomination spoken of by Daniel the
Prophet the standard of Rome being
uplifted and
encompassing God's people and putting
them under pressure
then you know that the time is near
so spoken off by the Prophet Daniel then
let them that be in Judea flee to the
mountains
in other words get out of the Cities yes
time is now
when you see Jerusalem compassed with
armies they know that the Desolation
thereof is now we are at that point
definitely like we've asked in the title
can you hear the rumbling
I can hear the rumbling of the Roman
army approaching
and it is a desolate Army it is devoid
of Christ
and anybody who adheres to it or
partakes in any form or fashion in its
Abominations
will not see Christ until he comes with
retribution
and some will receive a reward according
to their Works amen let's pray
Heavenly Father this is a very serious
topic
and I pray that you will grant wisdom
and understanding according to your
promise in Jesus name I pray amen amen
[Music]
foreign